President Trump is warning one of his
loudest critics in Congress who says his
cabinet members should be confronted in
public Democratic congresswoman Maxine
Waters has called for the president's
impeachment she heard sure supporters
last weekend to shame administration
officials over mr. Trump's policies the
president claimed yesterday that waters
called for harm to his supporters and
said be careful what you wish for
at O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill with the
loss of civility in politics and good
morning good morning Nora Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer didn't
name waters yesterday but said that no
one should call for the harassment of
political opponents that's not right
that's not American now anger is nothing
new in American politics you talk to
most Democrats though and they'd say
this all began during the 2016 campaign
when then candidate Trump openly taunted
his opponents and encouraged violence at
his campaign rallies the owner of the
red hen restaurant in Lexington Virginia
Stephanie wilkinson ignored our
questions about her decision to ask
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders to leave her restaurant we were
allowed to Grist disagree but we should
be able to do so freely and without fear
of harm Sanders addressed the incident
monday and denounced the threats made
against her healthy debate on ideas and
political philosophy is important but
the calls for harassment and push for
any Trump supporter to avoid the public
is unacceptable and if you see anybody
from that cabinet
but California Democratic congressman
when Maxine Waters declined to apologize
for those comments she made over the
weekend instead she blamed the president
for increased hostilities this time the
con man will say anything he is the one
that's responsible for promoting
violence it's the party of Maxine Waters
and his rally Monday the president only
briefly called out waters and made no
mention of Sanders but during Trump
campaign snaps in 2016 there were
physical confrontations and mr. Trump
didn't shy away from rhetoric promoting
violence like to punch him in the face
I'll tell you you see somebody getting
ready to throw a tomato knock the crap
out of avoid you seriously lawmakers
from both sides of the aisle are calling
for civility I would always hope that we
would appeal to our better angels we're
close to reaching rock bottom and
continuing to dig now an Arizona
congressman Andy Biggs issued a censure
motion on Monday night that condemns
waters he says that her comments quote
condone public violence and encourage
action that jeopardized the safety and
security of government officials it's
unclear when or if that censure motion
would ever get a vote John Eadie thanks
you know Nancy Pelosi the Democratic
leader in the house also like Chuck
Schumer basically rebutted what waters
had called for in a tweet so there is a
message coming from the leadership we're
not going to get voters that we need to
win back the house if this is the
rhetoric that defines our party yeah
they seem to be reluctant to mention her
by name I come from the two wrongs don't
make a right school it does seem like
we're on a big slope to get to the
bottom as fast as possible you know I
think a lot of people could use Michelle
Obama's memo they didn't get the memo of
you know when they go low we go high a
lot of people need that memo again okay
it's very unfortunate to see what's
happening I think on both sides well
nothing is gonna get done if we continue
this way nothing mm-hmm